ABOUT TWO INSIDE CHINA IS A
DIRECT BENEFICIARY.
THE FREE BEACON CAN REPORT THEY
WENT TO UNITECH, THE TRADING ARM
OF THE CHINA PETROCHEMICAL
CORPORATION.
THAT COMPANY IS WHOLLY OWNED BY
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT.
MEANWHILE, THE CCP.
HERE NOW IS DANIEL TURNER
FOUNDER OF POWER OF THE FUTURE.
I KEEP SAYING THIS IS BEYOND
DISTURBING, THE WORDS DON'T
CAPTURE THIS AT THIS POINT.
TELL US WHY THIS MATTERS, THERE
IS ALSO A BIDEN CONNECTION?
>> THIS IS DISTURBING ON
MULTIPLE LEVELS, THE PRESIDENT
TOLD US HE WAS RELEASING THESE
RESERVES TO LOWER THE PRICE OF
GAS NATIONALLY AND THEN YOU FIND
OUT THAT HE THREW SECRETARY
GRANT AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
ENERGY IS SELLING THEM ON THE
WORLD MARKET AND SELLING THEM TO
THE COMMUNIST CHINESE.
WE ARE SELLING OUR STRATEGIC RAW
MATERIALS, OUR STRATEGIC
RESERVES TO THE COMMUNIST
COUNTRY WHO IS OUR ADVERSARY AND
THEN YOU FIND OUT ONE OF THE
COMPANIES BROKERING THIS DEAL,
ONE OF THE TOP INVESTORS IS OF
COURSE HUNTER BIDEN.
THE PRESIDENT'S CRACKHEAD SON IS
INVESTED IN THE COMPANY THAT IS
BUYING OUR STRATEGIC RESERVES
WHILE WE ARE PAYING MORE THAN $5
A GALLON AT THE PUMP.
IF WE HAD AN IMPEACHMENT HEARING
ABOUT A PHONE CALL WITH
DONALD TRUMP AND
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY, IF THIS
DOESN'T CAUSE JERRY NADLER AND
ADAM SCHIFF TO ASK SOME
QUESTIONS AND FOR CONGRESS TO DO
ITS JOB AND WONDER HOW THIS
CRIME FAMILY IS PROFITING WHILE
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
SUFFERING, I DON'T UNDERSTAND IF
THERE IS AN OFFENSE MORE WORTHY
OF INVESTIGATING FOR
IMPEACHMENT.
>> Laura: WHERE IS
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" ON THIS?
WHAT IS THE JEFF BEZOS POST ON
THIS?
THIS IS A MASSIVE STORY.
PEOPLE ASK IF THE BIDEN FAMILY
IS OWNED BY CHINA BECAUSE THEY
ARE ABOUT TO LIFT THE TARIFFS
TOO, WE KNOW THAT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU SAY ABOUT
THIS.
IF THEY AREN'T OWNED BY CHINA
THEY ARE ACTING LIKE IT.
SPEAK OF THE PRESIDENT WANTS TO
USE THE DEFENSE AUTHORIZATION
ACT USING MILITARY POWERS TO
COMMANDEER THE PURCHASE OF WIND
AND SOLAR THAT ARE ALSO MADE IN
CHINA.
THANK GOODNESS FOR THE FREE
BEACON, COLLIN ANDERSON WHO
WROTE THE STORY DESERVES A SHOUT
OUT BUT I'M GETTING ANGRY AT
THIS FOR A VERY REASONS BECAUSE
THIS PRESIDENT JUST LAST WEEK
QUESTIONED OUR PATRIOTISM.
THE PRESS SECRETARY SAID WE ARE
NOT UPHOLDING OUR AMERICAN
STANDARDS.
WE HAVE BEEN TOLD WE ARE SHILLS
OF VLADIMIR PUTIN BECAUSE THE
GAS COMPANIES AREN'T LOWERING
PRICES, WE ARE ACCUSED OF PRICE
GOUGING AND PROFITEERING.
WHEN YOU FIND OUT HIS
ADMINISTRATION IS SELLING OIL ON
THE WORLD STAGE AND POTENTIALLY
HIS OWN FAMILY IS PROFITING FROM
IT.
THAT IS BEYOND OFFENSIVE.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
SENATOR MANCHIN WHO HAD THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE, I
WOULD LIKE TO THINK THEY WOULD
HAUL SECRETARY GRANHOLM WHO'S IN
CHARGE OF THIS AND ASK HER SOME
REALLY TOUGH QUESTIONS, WE ARE
PAYING $5 A GALLON BECAUSE OF
THIS ADMINISTRATION'S ENERGY
POLICY, NOW HIS FAMILY IS
POTENTIALLY PROFITING ON THE
WORLD MARKETS.
IT IS UNPATRIOTIC AND IT'S
SHAMEFUL AND POTENTIALLY
CRIMINAL.
>> Laura: MEANWHILE HE'S
BEATING UP THE MOM-AND-POP GAS
STATIONS, THAT'S THE GREAT PART
OF IT.
I'VE GOT TO PLAY THIS FROM THE
ECONOMIC ADVISOR FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE BRIAN D, HE INSISTED
THAT THE PRESIDENT IS FOCUSED ON
LOWERING GAS PRICES, WATCH.
>> WE HAVE TO SHOW ACTION ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WITH THE
PRESIDENT IS DOING.
EVERY DAY HE IS FOCUSED ON
PRACTICAL THINGS THAT HE CAN DO.
THE RELEASE OF OIL FROM
STRATEGIC PETROLEUM RESERVES --
SOUNDS ESOTERIC BUT OIL MARKET
ANALYSTS YOU'VE HAD ON THE SHOW
WOULD SAY IT'S SINGLE-HANDEDLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR KEEPING OIL
PRICES GOING HIGHER.
>> Laura: WHY DID HE SEND IT
TO OTHER COUNTRIES ESPECIALLY
CHINA THAT IS BUYING OIL FROM
RUSSIA THAT IS FIGHTING THE WAR
IN UKRAINE THAT WE ARE FIGHTING
A PROXY WAR AGAINST?
>> THAT'S EXACTLY IT, THEY ARE
CAUGHT IN A LIVE.
THEY ARE TELLING US THEY ARE
RELEASING THE STRATEGIC RESERVES
TO LOWER PRICES DOMESTICALLY AND
YOU FIND OUT THEY AREN'T
BRINGING IT TO AMERICAN
REFINERIES, THEY ARE SELLING IT
ON THE WORLD MARKET.
THEY ARE IN AN ABSOLUTE LIE.
THE SANCTION OF RUSSIAN OIL'S
MORAL DUTY THAT WE HAVE TO
SANCTION RUSSIAN OIL, ALL THAT
HAS DONE IS FORCE A GREATER
ALLIANCE BETWEEN RUSSIA AND
CHINA.
CHINA IS ALREADY PROFITING FROM
RUSSIAN OIL AT A PREMIUM AND NOW
THEY ARE PROFITING FROM AMERICAN
OIL AS WELL.
IT'S AN ADMINISTRATION -- PART
OF THE NEW LIBERAL WORLD ORDER,
THIS IS PART OF THE WORLD ORDER
BUT IS NOT WITH THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WANT AND THIS ELECTION,
THIS IS AN